uh hi everybody uh
i'm going to
tell you about the project enrp cross
cross-lingual eastern vaporeon index
this is a joint work with alexey tikonov
alex maclachup andrey manosh that's me
george dima rika sherhati mohammed sadek
hassan asif and matt sherry
let us begin first of all i want to
mention a few general things uh about
nlp that might be useful later first
thing is mutilation transformer language
phase model
well
well know that transformers uh conquered
the nlp world in the recent years and um
on the screen you see a few
bright examples as bird with lingual
bird material distilled in exam roberta
uh multilingual bird or
multilingual distilbert exam rabbit are
multilingual languages uh which have a
few very interesting properties
one of them is the thing called a
zero-shot cross-lingual transfer
what does it mean uh imagine we have
some initialized models here uh and we
have a two piles of text for example uh
one parallel text of text is in english
the other pile is in romanian
and if we portray
our big language model on these two
piles of unstructured text
and
next we have a some downstream task here
which we need to fine tune on for
example it will be a sentiment analysis
uh sentimented synthetic detection task
which is simply classification whether
uh the
sentence is uh carries good sentiment
bad or neutral
and
which is often the case we have labeled
that label that only on english language
uh and uh if we fine-tune uh
the model only on english language with
uh these english language
uh
uh the data pairs uh we can discover
that on other languages which
multilingual model is trained on uh
uh in other languages uh model will have
the same capabilities as if it was
fine-tuned on the armenian language for
example
that means that
when we trained on english data players
we have as well infer
on the russian data players armenian
data enterprise and whatever the
language model was originally trained
pre-trained on
yeah
uh
next step is a common sense reasoning
set of tasks uh it is a key tasks
in nlp world
and
there are quite a few examples of these
tasks
let's talk about nle for example uh nle
it is
kind of a classification task when we
are given two sentences and we want to
predict the relation between them
whether it is entailment whether their
synthesis contradict each other
or whether
they are not related at all
and on such tasks we later evolate uh
our models that we will that we will be
training
uh
and the next a few more words about this
across lingual trusted learning uh it is
the
quality of this corresponding transfer
depends on very large amount of things
uh some
outer speculates that it may it might be
similarities of languages shares of
model uh
vocabulary and
almost a very large amount of things
that could impact quality of data set
quality of similarity of
of languages
and that's kind of stuff that's kind of
stuff
yeah uh and
the thing is that uh most multilingual
models that we have now are often
represented on
only high resource languages such as
english language such as german such as
french and so on and we want
and uh we won't have uh not only these
high resource languages but also we want
label data for law resource languages
which help uh and some business tasks
which will have our
in research in the multilingual research
field uh and
this is a problem right now
which we intend to solve uh and next
thing that we mainly
focused on uh eastern european languages
uh
uh there are numerous and numerous
languages in eastern europe uh and uh
we focused on on only on these languages
because uh this project was first
started as a part of summer school by
deepmind eeml 2021 and later and uh and
later we
even published a paper
about this uh the paper was published on
el rec uh and in this june
if i remember correctly
uh and finally to our project we've made
um these contributions first we we built
a broad data set index we collected uh
all
data sets that we can find on uh
focused on low resource languages uh and
the index them in very convenient way
which will i will show you later uh the
same things we did to the models we
collected a large amount of models uh
bird-like gpt-like um
probabilistic models
and so on and frozen embedding models uh
and we built a few baselines with um
sorry but
too late or thoroughly uh
we also built uh benchmarks uh from
these collected data sets we
joined data sets with similar tasks to
build our new more broad data sets that
cover more and more languages and
with with these models and these
benchmarks we created a few baselines
okay let's start with the dataset index
uh
we collect uh
the number total number of collected
data sets is more than 90. we can see
them
in a minute
it is
yeah
if we if you go to the with the link you
can see uh
this index
on the rows you have
various languages
are albania and armenia and so on and
here you have tasks
these languages and tasks are systematic
in a very convenient way for example you
want to
solve there in a romanian just go to
this link
and
see what's going on uh the same thing we
did to the
oh
i closed my presentation
wait a minute okay the same the the same
thing we did to the model
models uh
the total number of collected models is
more than 60 um
and specifically we collected more than
20 language specific birth like models
and
you would you can go to the link too
and we'll see the similar structure
models and type types of models
you can find almost anything that exists
here or else or anything that existed
uh
this time
yeah and the very interesting thing also
is that we made it very very easy to
contribute uh if you want to
photo it later for now um
and we also made it
all these things are very easy to
contribute uh we you can just follow the
guidelines
you can to contribute you just have to
fork the repository add and uml file
about the data set on the model in the
folder and
these indexes will update automatically
that's all you need to do uh and we
created
a few benchmarks with these tasks um
from these models or from
us for these data sets and we evaluated
these benchmarks
when we related a few popular models on
multilingual models on these benchmarks
the models are multilingual bird
multilingual distilled bird and xlm
roberta and as a baseline as a business
we have
just simple birth and we can see that
indeed uh there is nothing that named
cross-lingual transfer uh because bird
for example didn't learn anything
uh this task is new skaters a
categorization by the way where we
just classifying some news
uh and also the interesting the
interesting interesting thing that we
can notice is that distillation uh
greatly reduces performance of
cross-lingual transfer for example you
can see that on english language quality
did not drop
to
too much
only for one and something percent but
on other languages we can see 7
11 and so on
so distillation is very bad for first
lineup transfer
and the
same
things for paraphrase detection
uh new sentiment detection tasks uh
uh uh also a few interesting interesting
things about new sentiment detection
task if you analyze this table you might
find that for some pairs of languages
cross-lingual transfer works really well
because these languages are semantically
similar
because they're from the same language
family or whatever
okay the same thing we can see we can
say for a twitter sentiment detection
task also we can notice that uh almost
everywhere in
such hard tasks that's sentiment
detection um
or nle uh
xml robert is a winner yeah
and
let's go to the conclusions uh
what we can say that multilingual
training is a key to zero-shot
cross-lingual transfer distillation
works not that good on current signal
transfer uh
xml roberta is a very good model one of
the models uh that
can achieve a nice performance with this
course signal transfer
and the quality and quality of transfer
uh is
impacted by similarity of languages
uh and in total we present indexes we
present benchmarks and we present and we
present emulations of some popular
models on these benchmarks
um
summit launches
acknowledgements
acknowledgements sorry uh we want to
thank we want to give thanks to email
organizers uh
uh or razvan and by erika and our mentor
thomas miglov
thanks for your attention and if you
have any questions
please ask them
[Music]
just a quick question okay did you like
find
births after after combining the data
sets together yes yes we we created new
benchmarks or for example let's say
about new categorization uh we created a
new benchmark that uh focused on these
categories from these data sets we
combined uh
in this case uh
eight eight
eight i can account yeah
uh we combined in eight data sets and
we trained on these data sets
uh
models
uh
xml layer and yeah
did you just write the translations
no we didn't tackle translation we
talked only
these classification type tasks
because translation uh
we actually might might
might work with translation but we
decided not to because uh our all our
data sets are focused on
some kinds of classification because for
good translation you often need to wear
a large amount of data sets are simple i
suppose uh
on very large data sets so all of them
were the monolingual data sets right
they weren't like a pair of the
translation or all of them were
monolingual right
like the classification tasks right
[Music]
all the data sets that you had uh had
labels on right
there wasn't any any pair like the
translation person no no their uh of
language but training was done only on
the
completely
unstructured and sorted on parallel
datasets
and even this uh
unsorted data sets uh when we train
model on uh
have a capability to do corresponding
transfer and also this is as far as i
know uh coin are quite unsolved question
why do we even have this cross-lingual
transfer because we don't have pipe
translation pairs uh but it turned out
that model uh even
such models as material
xml uh have the capability to understand
what does
what do we want on other languages uh
and this is interesting in the
interesting also because xml error for
example the biggest model of this tree
now cause indica can considered is not
that deep because we have gpt3 and
shield and megatron and blah blah blah
and the last question uh did you try
transfer learning to using this ember
for another task
like after translation this uh no
another uh from one task to another we
didn't try transcendental because
no we we did only we would we took only
one the
pre-trained models we took one dose
downstream tasks and we transferred our
models to this option just on top of
curiosity do you have any idea if if
they're working in another task is it
better or not right after combination
another tasks uh do you mean another
such as question answering like
transferring
i think that they
might be
but i'm not entirely sure uh to be
honest because we didn't evaluate
uh on such tasks when we let only on nld
data we will only on classification
type tasks
and you use only vertex models because
they're said to be good at
specifications thanks
hello everyone
as they said today we're gonna talk
about uh what can your telegram and more
specifically your telegram data tell
about you uh i think many of us use
telegram in messaging in daily life
can we just
like do the hand gesture if we use
oh the absolute majority kind of used to
use the telegram and
the best part of telegram is that
in comparison with other messengers it
allows us
regular users without opening any other
kinds of accounts to get to export our
data from telegram and
here we can see how we can
harness that data and what statistics
and what interesting fact we can get
from uh
risk from examining from analyzing our
telegram data
let's go
so
this is an ordinary guy let's name his
let's name him toros
and torres obviously uses telegram
what he does in his free time is
very similar to what all of us do
he
told us
does some chit chatting with his friends
uh
also exchanges memes fleets or discusses
some important startup ideas and so on
so generally speaking and so on so
generally speaking told us
we can see some image of tauros kind of
in
just based on on his telegram
interactions
uh
and
the the best part of telegram is that
taurus is not the only one there are
about uh 700
million people who use telegram uh i
mean this is the it is the number of
active users in telegram so you can
imagine how big that data is and how
many people can
get interesting insights from their
telegram accounts
for example like what are the simplest
things we can get from uh
analyzing tauros uh conversations and so
on uh we can know what are
his favorite words uh like about
everything about his vocabulary his
lexicon how it has evaluated
during months or even
in very small periods
we can figure out who are taurus's close
friends or at least
those who are on telegram uh
like who he loves to spend time chatting
with and which hours does he spend with
them uh and with that daily screen time
like uh maybe he uses three hours a day
miss telegram
we can find out his most emotional tests
like which are the most funny chats uh
which are uh
who is his crush kinda uh
which are lovely chats
when is he surprised when is he angry uh
we can also know who congratulated his
birthday first and uh
usually he starts the convo with a kind
of extrovert or introvert uh if we mail
it ourselves imagine that
uh and so on
and also uh when is the sleeping time uh
maybe we can all
maybe we all can agree that uh
we use telegram before our sleep and
i mean if we are active diagram users or
at least messenger users uh
we
actively chat before sleeping and also
when we wake up it is uh well usually
it's one of the first things we always
do
and uh
so what do we need for that
an ordinary told us we'll ask
we need data
or something like data-driven automatic
telegram analyzer
and
here we go
nepla telegram analyzer
behold naplow or we may pronounce it
netball
i don't know what is the correct
pronunciation
so this snaplog
now we're going to talk about what is
netflow and
we're going to see
how it's
how it performs in real time
so first naplo is an open source uh
python also online deployed so we can
everybody use everyone can use it from
our laptops right now without any
further installation or something and
it's also free and
i think these are the four uh
kind of main
points that
[Music]
netflow
can go with
what data do we give
actually telegram has
as i've said it has a wonderful feature
it helps us it
lets us to export our data and it is a
single file like a 50 megabyte file
which contains all of our conversations
and chats
and messages and when i say messages i
would mean that netflow uses the content
of these messages what is written there
the timestamps where each message is
sended and received
and also the types of messages
i mean stickers emojis or
images and so on
and maybe we can agree that we can get
some interesting insights from that kind
of data we'll see that uh
soon
and all we need to uh
everything
all taurus needs to do is to export this
data from telegram in json format it is
a one minute
thing and sometimes it's
it takes even less than one minute
upload it to netflow
and he can then play with tools and
magic buttons and see
some insights about his life
that
many of us don't
haven't
no
so
well those will ask where
where can i find this kind of data
this kind of an
analysis about my data as i've said uh
netlow is
is open source it doesn't take your data
and
we don't use it or something
so
let's follow this link and see
what network can do
oh
oh yeah i guess i know what's the
problem
here you can see the repository at
github
so where is netflow first we upload our
json file and i've uh
i've brought my own data
or at least some part of it we can see
it's 25 megabytes
let's wait for 5 seconds five seconds
and uh i'll show you all the features uh
netflow
obtains
is it is it
it does some pre-processing of this data
i mean the code is open source and
you can see what it does
great it is now it's now processed even
successfully uh
let me first scroll and show you uh
the features i mean there are not so
many but uh
certainly some of them are kind of
relevant
uh for example most notable days
like uh
what can most notable days mean in the
context in this context
uh he can see some uh kind of options we
can set let's go on uh for example it's
this is the simplest thing uh netflow
can tell us it says your longest
non-stop conversation by count happened
on this day
the same day it was also the length is
talking and
uh it tells us
when
kind of when did we spend
the longest active hours on telegram
my first message was sent on
2018
and
my record on send messages is on this
date and of received messages on that
date and so on
it's easily adjustable we can
kind of play with all these parameters
maybe we don't want to have the data
across all of my chat history we can uh
choose some some of my kind of
friends people i chat with we can select
albert for example and it will filter
out and uh leave us only with the data
uh from maya and albert's conversation
we can also have other
people and
now let's
go on trying
kind of the most interesting
things it can give us
i believe
we are
kind of
interested with the screen time like
when do i sleep and so on uh
let's delete this
yeah so we just select screen time per
day
uh
and it goes on and on from kind of every
day obviously we don't need this kind of
data oh we can see that uh something uh
is not right
okay let's try another thing this will
get fixed
longest gap in a chat
this one
amazed me because
this is showed
this one showed me
which person i used to talk uh
in the past and who disappeared for the
longest gap kind of uh we can see that
this user named you can see arata uh i
used to
chat with him
kind of two years ago
and then he disappeared and
this
he is disappeared for 652 days
another thing we can see
maybe what are
the most or least probable words to use
in the chat
uh for example we can see oh this is
kind of personal data actually but this
is my brother he he will not resent
uh
okay the the most probable things
most probable words are right to him
it's kind of his name and
okay whoever understands armenian uh i
can't know it's kind of
grand
oh
okay
for
humiliation like something like
boss home mommy grandma his name and so
on
uh
actually we can go into details but uh
let's move the technical part and uh
more concentrate on
okay for example word popularity by
chats
uh
for example we can
just input a word
for example python
let's say python and press enter it
filters out the message sent by me or to
me
i guess this is some problem
about my data
okay
i will inspect it and
it will get fixed
maximum conversations held at once
you can see
well based on this data
in a span of 15 minutes i have uh
i mean a couple of months ago i talked
to
three people at once exchanging eight
messages uh this is not
so impressive but actually uh
having a conversation with three
distinct people is
uh well somewhat uh
surprising say at least
uh typical startings and endings of a
conversation like how do people greet
each other
uh
oh here we can see uh
this is
and again for everybody who understands
armenian uh
this is this may be funny and who
doesn't understand it says kind of good
morning good day uh there are some
vocatives here like yes and uh and so on
we can
what is interesting is that when we
filter out one chat
kind of a person we talk every day to
and
it will tell us what are the most famous
kind of the most popular thing uh ways
we start the conversation or in the
conversation kind of good night or good
morning
we can do everything uh
in a nutshell we can do everything
related to
to work so
kind of my vocabulary we can see
the popularity the word usage per day
week month year
um what do i type when the
when the date just begins and uh and the
end of the days uh
we can see uh
oh this one is this one here is kind of
a daily message count over time
uh
okay maybe this one will take somewhat
longer but
okay
here we see a graph obviously we can
filter out and just leave
two or three people there uh to see
who whom do we chat with most as the
title says it filters out the daily
message count over time uh
like he is the uh
here we can see the date and he are the
recipients or the people who sent us
messages
and here's the count we can do the same
trick with time like how many hours
have i spent
talking to someone else and
just like we did with the count
word of the day or week or month or year
we can
well for it to be more interesting we
can filter out by month
okay let's start by the month
we can see the most popular words
on each month
uh
well usually it's not so
interesting i'm not gonna lie but
it's uh yeah
it's sometimes uh
yeah it's something
they tell me i have one minute uh just
one minute
uh
so there are about 30 features you can
explore all of them and obviously we
cannot concentrate on all of them uh we
can see
emotions by chat
i guess this is um
as you notice
on my data of about three years
the network works
well considerably
fast and
we can just
try all of these features in
in a couple of minutes or so
for example emotions by chat here we
have
the
we can set the filter for it not to
display all messages
oh okay
it just
okay it got reloaded that's maybe my bet
my time is over
or
but i'm
i'll be happy to answer any questions if
there are and we can go into details or
just
yeah
information on your friends
uh
well yes
as we have seen there there are commonly
filters like a message sent by me or
sent
to me
just ask them for their json file and
the rest will be done by netflow
i'll i mean i will try it uh
for for my friends who are not here i
will try to ask them for their files and
we'll try that way
well actually
the purpose of
kind of privacy is
that they don't give their messages to
us
unfortunately yeah
um so i suggest you to put
in the application
notifications
because it will uh
increase
probable users
for example to notify the person how
many hours is spent like for time
management
and also
if your networking is growing so you
you don't not about spending time about
how many messages
you send to how many people so i think
this will increase the
users
and
another question why nepl and with this
tilde
character oh yeah
actually a good insight and a good
question uh
thank you for your insight
i've done something like that like
counting the persons you're in
conversation with but then abandoned
that idea and
maybe if there is need we can add that
feature back uh and about name uh well
there is uh
again maybe
army population
would be familiar with that there is an
uh there's a telegram sticker pack which
features gorwartanyan
or one of his tv series and there is a
sticker
one of the stickers is
gore lying in bed and
there's a caption villain
which translates to uh
quite good or something like that
so netflow is the first uh five lectures
kind of a nipple
and then this yeah this tilde above and
is uh from spanish they they have letter
like that you might see was like
espanola or something like that
spelled with this letter
so
that's it for me i don't catch the point
uh why what is the proposed to know who
is my best friend or who can be my best
friend but for another person maybe it
can be proposed i don't know to know
which girls spend
more time
to sending messages i don't know
interesting interesting thank you
[Music]
thank you